[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue au parlement
européen ici à bruxelles pour un nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo
dans cette émission nous irons en
allemagne où la campagne pour les
élections européennes est lancée alors
que les britanniques cherchent une issue
aubry hésite et bien les allemands eux
manifestent en faveur de l'europe
mais quelle europe ce pays fondateur et
moteurs de l'union n'est pas forcément
favorable à l'europe sociale qu emmanuel
macron appelle de ses voeux
nous en débattrons en deuxième partie
mais d'abord parlons de la france qui
vient de créer une taxe sur les gaffes
assurent les géants du numérique
une initiative encore isolées l'union
européenne 1 n'arrivant pas à se mettre
d'accord sur une taxation commune
regardez
[Musique]
la france ouvre la voie elle crée sa
taxe gaffe à l'assemblée nationale vient
de donner son feu vert
c'est une taxe de 3% sur les entreprises
du numérique qui font au niveau mondial
plus de 750 millions de chiffre
d'affaires
la valeur est créée en france grâce aux
consommateurs français grâce aux données
françaises mais les impôts sont perçus
ailleurs en irlande ou aux états unis
il est à nos yeux inacceptable de voir
que les opérateurs numériques réalisent
des profits considérables grâce à vos
données grâce à nos données personnelles
alors que leurs profits sont beaucoup
moins taxés que ceux de nos pme
objectif éviter l'optimisation fiscale
pratiquée par les géants du web qui
préfèrent s'implanter dans les pays où
les impôts sont les plus bas en europe
ces géants pèsent environ 9 % d'impôt
contre 23% en moyenne toutes entreprises
confondues
c'est une taxe franco française à défaut
d'une taxe européenne car les 28 n'ont
jamais réussi à se mettre d'accord
mi mars ils ont enterré leurs projets
car quatre pays n'en veulent pas
l'irlande la suède le danemark et la
finlande
le commissaire européen aux affaires
économiques relativise cet échec au
départ y avait quatre ou cinq pays qui
étaient pour une taxe ou numérique
arrive il y en a à tous même 23 24 et
donc les leurs la prise de conscience a
été extrêmement forte
gaza qui se trouve que les règles de
décision à dire fiscales sont à
l'unanimité aujourd'hui pas d'échec
une étape qui n'a pas été totalement
conclusive
il faut regarder d'où nous venons y
avait rien les américains sont vent
debout contre cette taxe française sur
le web
paris tente d'impulser une taxe au
niveau international via l ocde
la commissaire européenne à la
concurrence veut croire que l'europe est
encore peser dans le débat
l'idéal serait une solution elle est
tellement qu'un doute l'absence within
risque bottin mais si on veut obtenir
des résultats quand sans délai
raisonnable il faut que l'europe prenne
la tête de cinéma des systèmes de fils
cadet autant dire qu'un accord
international sur une taxe numérique est
loin très loin d'être trouvé
[Musique]
et pour mieux comprendre ce débat j'ai
le plaisir de recevoir derek perrotte
bonjour bonjour vous êtes journaliste
pour le quotidien français les échos
correspondant ici à bruxelles
alors est ce que cette taxe gafa
européenne et renvoyer définitivement
aux calendes grecques
cc c'est difficile à dire ce qui est
certain c'est que maintenant ça va
prendre d'autres le dossier est un petit
peu enterrés au niveau européen on a
deux vagues promesses de le ressortir si
une solution internationale n'émerge pas
à terme les promesses par définition
engagent que ceux qui les croient en
plus elles sont effectuées par une
commission et un parlement européen qui
s'apprête à laisser leur place à un
nouvel exécutif européen beaucoup laisse
à croire que ce nouvel exécutif sera
moins europhile ou a donc
donc wait and see wait and see mais
effectivement aucune garantie en la
matière est-ce que ça a un sens d'avoir
une taxe uniquement française à quoi ça
va servir
moi j'ai tendance à penser que ça a un
sens parce que le point de départ qui
est de dire que la situation est injuste
fiscalement est aberrante économiquement
il est quand même plus ou moins
indéniable ensuite tout le monde
s'accorde à dire qu'une solution
européenne serait mieux qu'une solution
française et qu'une solution mondiale
serait mieux qu'une solution européenne
mais si on ne fait rien a tant qu'on n'a
pas de solutions mondiales ont fini on
risque de finir par ne rien faire
l'enjeu financier il n'est pas très gros
on évoque 4 à 500 millions de gains pour
la france à l'échelle du budget français
c'est pas énorme c'est loin d'être
négligeable mais c'est pas énorme a par
contre symboliquement symboliquement
c'est assez fort est ce qu'il y à
d'autres pays en europe qui se dirige
vers une taxe gaf a on voit pierre
moscovici le disais dans votre dans
votre sujet il a raison de le dire ça ça
a lancé et ça ouvert le débat
oui nous ne sommes pas la france n'est
pas là le seul état à viser quelque
chose de concret l'espagne est très
activement en train d'en préparer une
aussi à l'angleterre
et un certain nombre d'autres pays on
voit que la réflexion il monte et il
avance on voit dans le reportage c'est
la règle de l'unanimité qui a bloqué à
la décision fiscale au conseil européen
un seul pays votent contre
et c'est terminé est ce que cette règle
de l'unanimité peut être modifié et
comme ça ça c'est un gros sujet est un
vrai sujet qui dépasse la seule la seule
question de la taxe
gaffard et que c'est une question que
l'europe va devoir se poser elle n'a
plus le choix elle a commencé à se la
poser
jean claude juncker l'a mise sur la
table lors de son discours sur l'état de
l'union
il y a désormais un an et demi il l'a
ressorti à il ya quelques semaines avec
une proposition émise par les services
de pierre moscovici alors ils la
ressentent maintenant pourquoi parce qu
ils sont courageux mais pas téméraire
c'est un dossier extrêmement compliqué
donc c'est une manière de la laisser sur
le bureau de la la prochaine commission
mais ça c'est vraiment une question
essentielle ça changerait vraiment le
fonctionnement
ça changerait tout ça changerait tout
lol symboliquement ce serait un pas très
fort et dans les faits ce serait un
changement très conséquent parce
qu'effectivement on a ce dossier de la
taxe gaf a on voit bien que c'est
toujours extrêmement dur d'arriver à
être 28 à décider ce qu'il ya toujours
un moment où l'intérêt personnel prend
le dessus je pense pas sincèrement que
l'irlande soit opposé au principe d'une
taxe des fois je pense plus que
l'irlande est opposée au principe
d'embêter des très grandes entreprises
américaines
rezaï qui sont implantées chez elle je
pense pas que le luxembourg soit
foncièrement opposés à ça je pense que
le luxembourg veut pas embêtés amazon
qui est installé
chez elle donc cette question de
l'unanimité les vraiment centrale parce
que là on aborde sous l'angle de la taxe
gaza mais elle a bloqué un nombre
incroyable d'autres d'autres dossiers
qui pourraient quand même être
importants sont attendus des citoyens et
puis il faut voir aussi qu'elle bloque
beaucoup de petits dossiers où l'opinion
publique s'en rend moins compte il y en
a un très intéressant pour ça c'est
qu'en fait qu'est-ce que c'est
l'unanimité c'est un droit de veto est
un droit de veto c'est quoi c'est un
droit de chantage on ait eu un dossier
qui s'est enfin débloquer ces derniers
mois c'est la tva réduite pour la presse
en ligne et pour les pour les
publications en ligne d'hier vous pouvez
avoir une tva réduite comme l'ont déjà
les journaux classiques
tout le monde était d'accord on a mis
trois ans à la faire parce qu'il ya un
pays qui était la république tchèque qui
bloquait le dossier en le prenant en
otage sans même s'en cacher parce qu'il
voulait obtenir quelque chose d'autre
sur un autre dossier
voilà ce genre de choses c'est vraiment
vraiment problématique alors dernière
question rapidement est ce que vous
croyez à la création d'une taxe gafa au
niveau international pour tout le monde
là aussi on verra c'est un petit peu
compliqué c'était très bloquée à l' ocde
le sentiment que j'ai et beaucoup
d'autres observateurs c'est que ça peut
aider quand même à faire bouger les
lignes margairaz de vesta hier le disais
dans votre sujet la raison quand il dit
il faut qu'on arrive
23 24 25 26 pays européens favorables
ça peut faire bouger les lignes après a
pas se mentir on sait tous que ça va
énormément dépendre de l'attitude des
états unis à quelle sera l'attitude des
etats-unis vis-à-vis des gaffes à on
voit quand même qu'elle change un petit
peu pour l'instant sur le dossier
données personnelles
il ya quelques évolutions dont il faut
voir pour les pas perdus
certes un peu ça brûlait un peuple c'est
quelque chose de long et qui sera long
et qu'il arrive merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous sur ce plateau et cette
semaine nouvelle étape de notre tour
d'europe
al'approche des élections européennes on
s'intéresse cette semaine à l'allemagne
c'est un reportage de clément perreault
à berlin où le sentiment pro-européen
domine la campagne électorale
[Musique]
ils se tiennent par la main et dansant
ronde pour célébrer l'union européenne
la scène pourrait surprendre ailleurs
mais pas à berlin en allemagne est un
bastion europhile le mouvement pulse of
you up le pot de l'europe en appel au
coeur des citoyens européens contre les
fièvres nationaliste beaucoup de gens
soutiennent l'europe mais je pense
qu'ils ne sont pas assez visibles
il n'y a aucun mal à se sentir français
ou allemands mais c'est bien aussi de se
sentir européen et d'être unis ce
mouvement se veut indépendant mais les
partis politiques ne se font pas prier
pour venir
crédité l'un comme l'autre d'environ 20%
des intentions de vote
les sociaux démocrates et les verts se
disputent cet électorat pro européen
nous avons beaucoup d'objectifs communs
avec ce mouvement
nous nous battons pour une europe
solidaire contre le nationalisme et le
populisme
nous nous battons pour avoir un vrai
débat européen et non des débats
nationaux
je pense que la majorité des personnes
présentes ici vont voter pour des
mesures progressistes comme un salaire
minimum européen
cette idée d'un smic européen est
défendu par emmanuel macron et le figure
dans sa lettre aux européens publiée le
4 mars
mais ce courrier du président français a
été modérément appréciée par l'axé d où
la parti d'angela merkel
sa candidate berlinoise hildegarde 29
tracts dans les faubourgs opaba l'amt
actifs en allemagne pour pouvoir de 14
ans est crédité de 30% d'intentions de
vote
l'accès des ou défend l'orthodoxie
budgétaire est d'accord sans ménagement
le président français je trouve ça
formidable
quand un chef d'état sort de ses
prérogatives nationales pour s'engager
dans le débat européen
mais il gagnerait en crédibilité s'il
trouvait des solutions pour son propre
pays et je pense que la france a
aujourd'hui de gros problèmes avec la
montée de l'extrême droite et le
mouvement des gilets jaunes chez des
entreprises allemandes aussi la lettre
venue de paris a été plutôt mal perçue
nous sommes chez mène seule une usine
qui produit des moteurs industriels
ici la direction ne voit pas d'un très
bon oeil les projets d'harmonisation
sociale européenne
les allemands tiennent à leurs propres
règles des horaires de travail plus
souple et des cotisations patronales
plus faibles hors de question d'une
europe centralisée qui dicterait ces
règles le centralisme est beaucoup plus
répandu dans d'autres pays d'europe
qu'en allemagne
si des décisions sont prises à bruxelles
elles doivent être valides pour tout le
monde mais je pense que l'on gagnera en
rapidité et en flexibilité en continuant
comme aujourd'hui à pouvoir prendre des
décisions localement j'ai peur qu'une
europe plus centralisée n'aboutisse au
contraire à encore plus de règles et de
normes
sur les questions économiques
la méfiance que l'europe inspire parfois
aux allemands s'est transformée pour
certains en défiance nous sommes à un
débat organisé par l'afd le parti
d'extrême droite
pour ses partisans le message sur
l'europe est simple
marre de payer pour les autres nous
sommes les trésoriers de l'europe c'est
nous qui payons le plus un impôt sur nos
retraites sur tout le temps et cet
argent il est toujours pour les autres
pays jamais pour nous nous
impressionnant beaucoup les autres pays
du coup ils se disent que l'allemagne
paiera pour tout et que ne paieront rien
montré le feu au sein de ce parti
certains leaders vont jusqu'à se poser
la question d'une sortie de l'allemagne
de l'union européenne à une organisation
une organisation qui n'est pas capable
de se réformer et condamné à mort si
l'union européenne ne change pas et se
réfugie dans l'immobilisme
si elle persiste à mener la même
politique alors je ne vois pour elle que
le néant et alors je pense que
l'allemagne pour sera sérieusement à la
quitter et avec elle d'autres
cette sortie de l'allemagne
baptisé d'exceet reste un scénario
inenvisageable aujourd'hui l'afd
plafonne autour de 10% d'intentions de
vote alors que les scores conjugués des
partis pro-européens frôle les 60 15%
dans les dernières enquêtes
alors on l'a vu dans le reportage la
lettre d' emmanuel macron sur l'europe
n'a pas forcément été bien accueillis en
allemagne madame morin chartier est ce
que la lune de miel entre macro et les
dirigeants allemands est terminée non je
ne crois pas que la lune de miel soit
terminé d'abord ça me ferait beaucoup de
peine parce que ici au parlement
européen il faut savoir qu'on ne réussit
rien tout seul ça n'est pas un groupe
politique qui peut faire passer une
directive tout seul c'est forcément dans
des alliances dans la construction de
consensus entre les différents groupes
politiques et c'est une utopie que de
laisser croire que attention on arrive
et tout va changer
non ici tout est dans le dialogue dans
le respect dans la concertation et
l'europe c'est ça en fait l'europe c'est
une coopérative
il faut être tous ensemble pour porter
un projet européen
je suis d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
dans le reportage
l'europe doit évoluer l'europe
d'aujourd'hui dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui ne peut plus être l'europe
des années 50 et en particulier et je
viens des styles totalement l'europe
sociale doit être un volet essentiel de
l'europe d'aujourd'hui et de l'europe de
demain
monsieur wenger ne vous avez
l'impression vous que la lune de miel
entre emmanuel macron les dirigeants
allemands est terminée ou pas vraiment
mais je ne sais pas s'il ya jamais eu
lune de miel c passable et je crois ce
qui est certain que le gouvernement un
monde notamment parce qu'elle est ne
veut pas soutenir certaines souhait de
la france notamment dans la politique
monétaire et cetera est plus incliné de
soutenir par exemple certaines 2
certaines suède est de la france dont la
politique sociale par exemple dans toute
la discussion sur la la directive des
travailleurs détachés et c'est en
principe les allemands ont soutenu la
france bien que ça c'était pas vraiment
leur on va en reparler
on va en reparler oui ça a été plus
nuancé que ça c'était plus nuances et y
est d'accord mais on aurait pu imaginer
seulement de la position des allemands
que les allemands ne ne sont mois
coopérative là-dessus ce qu'ils étaient
toujours dans le passé madame arena quel
est votre point de vue vous vu de
belgique sur ce couple franco allemand
alors je pense que ce sont bien entendu
des pays importants des pays fondateurs
des pays on l'a dit avec une démographie
importante avec un des moteurs
économiques importants et il est bien
entendu essentiel que des pays tels que
cela dialogue essaye de trouver des
consensus bien sûr mais l'europe se
limite pas à la france et à l'allemagne
nous sommes aujourd'hui 28 pays avec des
réalités qui sont parfois des réalités
différentes des pays qu'on appelle
parfois périphériques qu'ils ne sont pas
dans cette logique qui est la logique
franco allemande et qui ont parfois des
difficultés aussi à l'intérieur de
l'europe et donc je pense qu'il est
important que ce couple franco-allemand
existe je pense que c'est aussi notre
histoire de la construction européenne
mais que cette dynamique puisse aussi à
faire une dynamique inclusive par
rapport à la construction européenne et
ça me semble essentiel et d'ailleurs je
trouve que au niveau du discours et
j'entendais le les témoignages des
citoyens allemands qui avaient
l'impression finalement que l'allemagne
était je dirais le pays qui paye pour
tout le monde le grand argentier de
l'horreur en fait l'allemagne est un des
pays qui bénéficient le plus de l'essor
européen
on n'en parle pas on n'en parle pas
assez et je pense que les citoyens
auraient tout à gagner je pense que le
gouvernement allemand aurait tout à
gagner d'expliquer beaucoup plus aux
citoyens allemands ce que l'europe
apporte à l'allemagne en matière de
développement économique par exemple
et quand on parle de leurs
doxi budgétaire je trouve qu'il est
particulier d'entendre de la part de
certains élus allemands qu'il faut
imposer cette orthodoxie budgétaire à
l'ensemble des pays européens
vous savez l'orthodoxie c'est aussi
quand on a des surplus ce il faut
pouvoir les réinvestir dans plus de
pouvoir d'achat + 2 et donc si on parle
par exemple du nuc du niveau de revenu
qui permet d'avoir plus de pouvoir
d'achat l'allemagne a aussi un travail à
réaliser quand elle a des surplus
budgétaires de pouvoir les réinvestir
sur sa population pour faire en sorte
qu'il y ait une augmentation du
bien-être des citoyens allemands alors
on voit que la question de
l'harmonisation des droits sociaux en
europe fait partie de la campagne en
allemagne qu est-ce que l'allemagne
craint qu est ce qu elle a à perdre si
l'europe devient plus sociale de votre
point de vue monsieur wenger tient les
manettes à mon papa des soucis que
l'europe devient plus sociale ça c'est
pas de problème je crois c'est un peu
polémique
le je crois les amants de soucis d'abord
nature moins ils ont le souci de plus
intégré les pays de l'est
c'est à dire l'europe sociale et nature
mon âme problème les différences sont
énormes entre la france l'allemagne et
la pl la pologne la bulgarie et cetera
c'est à dire si on veut avoir par
exemple un salaire minimum européen a au
même niveau
ça veut dire qu'il ya des dd des
subventions énormes qu'il fallait
l'objectif c'est pas l'objet a été dit
de manière générale on s'est beaucoup
beaucoup de gens voient ça comme ça
naturellement il ya des malentendus ya
des cd des malentendus voulu
bien sûr mais c'est c'est comme ça
qu'elle s'est introduit aussi dans la
discussion et on les remet à l'entente
les nouvelles pour informer nos
concitoyens une bonne information
notable il ne s'agit pas de laisser
croire qu'il y aura un sig europea
identique dans l'ensemble des pays
européens
c'est absolument impossible aujourd'hui
le smig au luxembourg ses 2200 euros par
mois et en bulgarie c'est 260 euros par
mois donc comment voulez vous imaginez
d'un seul coup d'un seul vendre à
l'europe entière et demain tout le monde
va être évidemment on vous sent c'est
dans les rêves orbite au smic
luxembourgeois mais non ce n'est pas
cela
c'est finalement un salaire minimum
qu'ils soient proportionnelles et des
cent par rapport au salaire moyen de
chaque état membre
notre problème aujourd'hui à tous à tous
les peuples européens
c'est de faire converger cette europe
vers un niveau de vie qui permettent aux
ex pays de l'est de rattraper l'histoire
sociale politique et économique qu'ils
ont il faut avoir le courage de le dire
madame anna marina qu'est ce que vous
pensez vous de cette de cette
proposition de mettre un salaire minimum
différent dans chaque pays européen mais
un salaire minimum quand même bien sûr
je partage tout à fait l'analyse qui est
faite par madame morin chartier ce que
nous avons proposé c'est de dire que
chaque pays doit mettre en place un
mécanisme de concertation pour
l'établissement d'un salaire minimum
dans son pays
c'est à dire qu'on ne puissent plus
avoir des systèmes qui sont complètement
divergents avec des avec une vraie
concurrence qui s'établit à l'intérieur
même d'un pays et à l'extérieur du pays
aujourd'hui nous sommes pour la libre
circulation des travailleurs c'est une
des choses fondamentales en europe
mais cette libre circulation doit
pouvoir se faire non pas en abusant du
fait que certains travailleurs ne soit
pas correctement payés et en leur
proposant je dirais de quitter leur pays
tout simplement parce qu'ils seront
mieux payés ailleurs et donc il faut que
chaque pays
fasse le travail pour que chaque
travailleur se sentent émancipé dans son
propre pays
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce problème
le salaire minimum au contraire a dit un
jour si on a un salaire minimum vous
accentuez la problématique
on a aujourd'hui une libre circulation
des services une libre circulation des
travailleurs et ça c'est une deux des
quatre libertés fondatrice de l'europe
que nous partageons dans les 28 états
membres
mais aujourd'hui avec ces différences de
salaires on à du dumping social entre
les salariés à l'intérieur du marché
unique européen et on a de la
concurrence déloyale entre les
entreprises c'est à dire qu'on a là les
deux ferment qui vont permettre au
populisme au repli national de se
développer à travers l'europe c'est ce
sur quoi nous travaillons pour sortir de
ce dumping social et de cette
concurrence déloyale
sans remettre des murs entre les pays ce
n'est pas ça l'europe
mais vous me le rendre un vin de garde à
vous êtes très sceptique sur ce
salariale il ya un véritable conflit il
faut vraiment le dire il ya un conflit
entre les européens de l'est qui veulent
profiter de leur avantage d'avoir des
coûts de salaire relativement bas c'est
qui est un avantage dont la concurrence
et les pays les anciens pays de l'est de
l'europe la france l'allemagne et cetera
qui ne veulent pas que leur niveau
d'huile soit mise en question par cette
concurrence et qui sait que c'est un
conflit c'est un véritable conflit pour
voir et on avait on avait jusqu'en 96 on
a déjà eu un compromis
on a trouvé un compromis dans ce conflit
on a dit que les pays de l'est ce dédale
l apix à l'époque c'était encore le
portugal et l'angleterre
ces pays-là doigts peuvent travailler
dans le centre dont la france
l'allemagne et cetera mais au moins pour
le pour le salaire minimum mais ils
n'ont pas le droit à toute la barre m 2
des salaires et 7 s'est compromis là
quand la commission à la mis en question
avec la nouvelle directive met depuis la
bataille reparti clairement non viables
à kayes la bataille est pas d'accord
terme ou lis je ne suis pas d'accord et
j'aimais mon gars je me laissais dixit à
ma fille masques d'alaska ont échangé
dans la directive travailleurs détachés
beaucoup de choses ça va et vient c'est
à dire que maintenant la ligne politique
c'est à travail égal salaire égal sur le
même lieu de travail est la référence
n'est plus uniquement le salaire minimum
du pays d'accueil
mais la rémunération et qu'est ce que ça
change et la rémunération tout ça change
les bonus qu'ils sont attachés
ça change le 13e mois une de pénibilité
la prime de vibrations c'est à dire qu'à
manille ainsi à léguillac c'est un
nouveau compromis qui intègre justement
les pays de l'est parce que sa directive
de casser l'ess n'a pas accepté ce
serait savoureux et voulait pas dire son
nom je ne veux pas vous laisser dire ça
ça va quand même alors je la directive a
été voté à 70 % des voix au parlement
européen exactement biens dont les
votants me nadia aussi il y avait des
pays de l'est surtout je pensais le
conseil tout le monde était d'accord et
on a même élargi la majorité au conseil
je pense que c'est un peu résumé de dire
les pays de l'est sont contre et les
pays du centre les pays fondateurs sont
pour
il faut savoir qu'il ya des
organisations syndicales par exemple
dans les pays de l'est qui ont prôné la
protection de ces travailleurs en disant
nous sommes pour la mobilité bien sûr
mais nous voulons que nos travailleurs
bénéficient aussi du bien-être des
travailleurs qui sont des travailleurs
des pays fondateurs et donc c'est une
amélioration aussi pour les travailleurs
issus des pays qui sont des pays
d'europe centrale qui ont vont avoir
plus de pouvoir d'achat qui vont pouvoir
aussi relancer la machine
dans leur pays parce que c'est personnes
retournent dans les pays d'origine
pour l'instant ce qui n'a pas changé
c'est la différence de cotisations
sociales entre par exemple les pays de
l'est et l'europe ou l'allemagne lana
feu la chef de file du parti des manuels
mâcon pour les européennes proposent par
exemple qu'un chef d'entreprise qui
envoie son travailleurs bulgares par
exemple en france paye les cotisations à
la hauteur des cotisations sociales
françaises avec la france via un fonds
européens pourraient renvoyer ces
cotisations dans le pays d'origine du
travailleur qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette proposition alors je dois avouer
que j'avais proposé cela quand on a
discuté sur la directive détachement
parce que c'est vrai que la composition
du salaire c'est bien entendu le revenu
poche le salaire poche du travailleur
mais c'est en plus la couverture sociale
pension la couverture maladie et donc
cette couverture sociale
elle fait la différence entre un
travailleur français un travailleur
belge est un travailleur bulgare et donc
il serait intéressant aussi pour aller
vers la convergence est à dire comment
donner plus de couverture pension à un
travailleurs bulgares et bien c'est en
ayant un fonds de solidarité qui
permettrait de couvrir effectivement ce
droit social pour le travailleur
pourquoi un travailleur bulgare n'aurait
pas droit à une pension digne de deux
sacs de de sa prestation
dernière question monsieur wenger vous
que pensez vous de cette proposition est
ce que ça vous paraît possible à mettre
en oeuvre techniquement nativement c'est
possible je pense politiquement
politiquement non je pense pas qu'en bon
bah pouvoir ça les amis m'ont pas
accepter ça je pense et nie pas mal
d'autres pays mais de toute façon on
peut toujours convaincre c'est toujours
aussi des ddd discours des marchandages
cetera bien surprenant sur pas des
marchands d'achat du tout c'est la
construction d'un conte station mais si
l'allemagne ne souhaite pas
pas grave l'essentiel c'est qu'on est
des majorités donc nous s'il nous semble
important d'avoir ce fonds de
péréquation en fermant sur les droits
sociaux et bien nous allons
travailler à faire une majorité on va
construire le consensus donc si on veut
d'une europe sociale
il faut qu'on la fasse avec tous ceux
qui ont cette volonté de faire l'europe
sociale et je dois vous dire que moi je
suis extrêmement confiante parce que
entre les différents groupes politiques
jusque là on est arrivé à faire un très
bel accord une très belle convergence
parce qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
directives aussi pointu qui sont votées
par 70% des députés et puis aussi au
conseil est donc pour moi c'est un
espoir donc l'envers la 4e tour s il
faut tenir la passe et ce que vous nous
dites
pour finir cette émission merci beaucoup
à tous savoir était avec nous merci à
vous de votre fidélité à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]